that's a very good question they will
only happen if the other parties agree
to accept the Prime Minister's proposal
and there's no sign of that I mean the
whole thing looked at from outside and
sort of putting aside some of the
rhetoric the whole synchrony look studly
undignified and it does not in any way
assist the reputation of politics as a
whole look at these seven party leaders
people who are saying they can't even
agree on a debate and the form of a
debate and this as you've heard said
many times in your program is one of the
most fascinating most interesting most
uncertain general elections for a very
long time all the more reason one would
think and the public will think that
there should be a proper structure of
debate I mean does it actually matter
for democracy for a full and fair
election whether or not the debates take
place I think it gives people an
opportunity to form of you about
character and character is increasingly
important than the kind of general
elections that we have in this country
now and it seems to me the election will
take place debates or no debates but if
for example you're making a proposal
which involves spending public money or
not as the case may be then if these
debates take place in advance of the
publication of manifestos then every
time a journalist like yourself might
ask a difficult question of any one of
the leaders they'll simply say well
let's wait we'll give you detailed
costing swim we launched our manifesto
the idea that you can do this before the
party's programs are not fully in front
of the British people seems to me to be
visible and that I think may and the end
be the thing which took Peters the whole
idea put forward by the Prime Minister
on the other hand do you think there
will be any physical cost to him if he
successfully manages to stop these
debates going ahead well remember it's
one of the first rules of the general
election isn't it the opposition always
wants debates and the Prime Minister
always refuses them except of course
Gordon Brown in the last election and I
think his experience and what people
remember
his experience is such that it would be
very very curious indeed if there was a
concerted push from the conservatives at
least to have debates but Luke public
opinion on this is going to be very very
important and because this issue has
been raised so far out from the general
election after all we've watched six
weeks away then I think this particular
issue has got time to fester and I think
anyone who says well the Prime Minister
will not be affected by this is pinning
his or her hopes on something which may
not come about I mean I mean why is that
you think that there could be a cost of
being seen to be a chicken or a coward
or a humbug of some kind yeah yeah I
mean I don't like the language but if
you've been the prime minister for five
years if you want to be the Prime
Minister for the next five years
shouldn't you be willing to take part in
a sensible debate once the policy
programs of all the seven political
parties have been put to the public
isn't that what you would expect another
thing you need to throw around
accusations of fright or something of
that kind I think it's just a crush the
respecting public opinion saying loot
you want to invest your authority and me
very good here's what I'm willing to do
and to say when you question me about
how I will exercise that authority of
course the conservative counter-argument
is that being seen on equal terms with
the Prime Minister raises up people in
the way that it raised up Nick Clegg for
example during the twenty ten general
election well the answer to that is of
course that this is going to be a
multi-party election far more of a
multi-party election than we've ever had
and should not minority views be
represented should they not be reflected
in the way of which this is this whole
matter is covered we don't know i mean
even if i sir old professionals like
yourself and myself we are not in a
position to predicting what the outcomes
going to be I can't remember a general
election of which you could safely say
that and in these circumstances I think
different rules apply and certainly
different public expectations will apply
therefore a failure to respond to these
publication to these expectations could
well be very very damaging means caramel
thank you very much